hello and welcome to this video playing
pop while 29 I have played him a lot in
the past but not not not oops not not
recently don't remember at least so we
have this this line in the sicilian and
usually white is playing for F for
breaks well black tries to put a knight
on d4 so okay if he gives me this Bishop
I'm also fine with it Oh puts it over
there it's a quite uncommon as the
bishop is normally not that well placed
on on g6 okay a couple of interesting
ideas here can on like this 92 to see 40
k 5 is helping me so here we go so he
tries to play it with f6 and then Bishop
f7 ok f4 it's not that easy to get in
was my idea to play quick f4 I kind of
have to otherwise a very little in terms
of ideas here let's see what is doing Oh
castles law okay so probably now f5 if I
take i-5 he takes on c4 so I go at 5pm
it should be nice for winder he has a
hard time to play be five okay so night
ace for the sea doing their night a
six-night 86 before maybe
hmm ok so let's do this pretty much
night is not that's wrong I wanted to
say it forces it forces a b6 but it
doesn't actually do that so i have this
night on this night is not good getting
it to be three would be cool but I don't
see don't see how
okay I think I'll just cancel him c5
know is hanging oh that's a cool
solution yeah I don't take this I don't
take only for maybe I actually should
now we can take and play maybe be five
even be five yes and I remember from the
earlier games this is kind of fancy
aggressive player always playing
enterprising stuff I should have taken
the rope maybe
yeah I should have taken the bloody
rogue earlier
I basically didn't want to take it like
on principle like okay I don't I just
don't play along with your ideas that
was the attitude behind it but I should
have just considered it and probably
taken it
okay it's definitely dangerous for white
yeah but I don't I don't see something
terrible immediately okay Bishop takes
takes a two is N and bishops III yeah
okay if you give this to a computer just
says white wins that's pretty clear but
if I manage to do it here in the game
it's some other matter yeah the next
exchange sec then I'm definitely not
taking I mean I need this bishop for
defense i'm pretty sure they're okay but
how do i actually win and turn enter
this is somehow
if he doubles time morning secure that
actually would threaten something
ah for the game what a bloody game check
check now black is winning yes far too
many porn Sam for me to stop near justy
tune well maybe objectively it is ok
actually for me but I have got 11
seconds
body game yeah that's it it's not easy
to defend this even even if it's
completely completely bonkers like
resins yeah I mean this is a of course
totally winning who I but defending it
is different in in blitz and probably I
should just take that bloody rue p.m. I
mean it'sit's this is playable for black
of courses exchange sacrifice when maybe
I should just check in and take it I
yeah night a 2 was definitely wrong
because this allows this p5 move this is
definitely wrong I saw that I just I
just didn't didn't think yeah my day to
properly I wanted to get rid of that
piece because it's annoying but then I
just have to stay put here and see that
b5 doesn't work I can I can still play
useful moves on the Kings side is what
I'm trying the same and it's not clear
what he is doing yeah the computer lines
aren't not helpful computer gives this
which is just just good for wide yeah
this is kia I don't absolutely have to
avoid him having playing that he plays
be five I have to avoid that it is
getting really really bad and this was
this was a lot stronger I have no good
square now and I'm getting killed get
this this way I got into a position
where white should really win but again
I couldn't do it I mean
I fell to some we had stuff with no time
on the clock so taking us actually doing
it yeah pawn takes rook g7 is simple and
here I can you can take and just play
with them with the material yeah yeah
okay doesn't tell him it's just what it
is if you have the such a messy position
you can always lose it no matter how
correct that position objectively is
here we also could have played rugby one
and so on but anyway check Jim yeah it
does matter i have 17 seconds it doesn't
matter what the position is like okay
guys thanks for watching